boa noite
é um prazer imenso estar aqui com vocês
principalmente pela oportunidade de
trazer um pouco uma forma diferente de
pensar de uma forma que com certeza
podem contribuir bastante com todos e
falo isso com tanta convicção porque ao
longo do tempo a sobrevivência indígena
dependeu muito dessa forma de pensar
trata se de uma maneira diferente de
encarado uma forma nova
uma forma revolucionária na verdade
somos programados naturalmente para
fugirmos da dor
eu sou professor da universidade federal
de alagoas
ela é o do aula e com uma disciplina
chamada bases biológicas do
comportamento e ao ensino aos alunos num
primeiro momento que uma ameba uma única
célula quando você toca nela com agulha
de um micromanipulador ela se retrai
ela foge os alunos ao saberem disso logo
eles percebem que tudo que aversivo
causa qualquer dano a gente gera um
afastamento assim a nossa relação com a
dor
na maior parte dos casos sempre a gente
entender a dor com um aviso de algo que
é desagradável que pode nos trazer
prejuízos
então eu venho aqui neste palco hoje com
este objetivo de fazer vocês compreendem
a dor de uma maneira diferente a do que
ensina e sempre que a gente fala do que
ensina a gente junta alguma coisa com
aprendizagem e tudo o que significa
aprendizagem já faz o mundo brilhado uma
maneira diferente mas eu estou falando
só sobre a dor de uma maneira genérica
eu vim aqui também para falar sobre
índios mas não os índios que as pessoas
estão habituadas a conceberem distante
da nossa realidade mas o índio que
reside na agenda enquanto o brasileiro
pelo fato de sempre nos afirmarmos
também como fruto de uma trilha de um
atrito é composta pelo negro pelo branco
e pelo índio mas que insistimos em
retirar da sala um desses personagens
que o personagem dele e assim como
eu parti de vocês durante a infância eu
também não fiquei muito atento ao que de
fato eu era
acho que ninguém pensa dessa forma
ninguém fica preocupado com o que a
gente fica muito mais preocupado sempre
viver enquanto eu vivia foi na escola
sendo vítima de algum tipo de chá suco
de preconceito que eu comecei a pensar
que provavelmente a minha realidade era
diferente
somente em contato com os alunos que eu
queria brincar com eles e eles não
permitiram que eu brincasse por ter uma
cor de pele diferente com
características diferentes que eles têm
alguma coisa diferente
somente aos e veementemente repreendido
por uma professora que afirmava que as
palavras que utilizava não eram palavras
comuns e que não existiam no dicionário
foi que eu fui até minha casa e
perguntei à minha mãe
mas mãe uma que polly de onde saiu isso
como que as palavras que a gente fala um
cidadão português
e aí minha mãe com carinho absoluto
disse meu filho é que essas palavras são
muito particulares da nossa realidade
pouco que tem pipoca pequim
me dá um team mondher que significa
armadilha eram palavras que não estavam
compostas no dicionário e que por isso
estavam gerando também algum tipo de
preconceito
então eu pensei eu possa adotar uma
postura vitimiza tória uma postura em
que eu me anulado devido todo esse mau
trato mas eu posso também aprender com a
dor e transformar isso em algo
completamente diferente
eu refleti porque eu estava indo atrás
dessas pessoas porque eu queria algo
havia algo nelas que me despertava
desejo eo então movimento não precisava
se apenas esse em que eu ia até eles
eu poderia gerar um outro tipo de
movimento eu poderia gerar um movimento
em que eu tenho certeza que também tenha
coisas que também poderia provocar o
desejo dessas pessoas
a partir daí eu estabeleci uma relação
diferente não uma relação em que focava
no preconceito mas uma relação que eu
poderia saber
seu sistema de troca ora mas o sistema
de troca em que eu tenho que oferecer
algo e se algo foi a semente inicial do
que a gente chama hoje de ouricuri
caiçara
a proposta era convidar essas pessoas
para um programa um verdadeiro programa
de índio é no brasil entender programa
língua sempre algo muito ruim e aversivo
eu não podia fugir disso
de verdade eu convido as pessoas para
sofrerem voluntariamente e por incrível
que pareça isso se tornou objeto de
desejo das pessoas
isso ainda pode parecer distante da
realidade das pessoas
mas se a gente pára para pensar
muçulmanos e cristãos budistas pessoas
no mundo inteiro que fazem reflexão
elas procuram voluntariamente a dor que
elas procuram voluntariamente a dor
porque elas entendem que a dor e as
transforma temendo isso eu vi que eu
poderia receber unificar a vida de muita
gente poderia impactar de um modo
diferente se fizesse essas pessoas
entrarem em contato com a dor de um modo
diferente que entendeu
daí eu precisava mostrar para elas que
não existem pessoas grandes não existe
um único só homem que fez história e não
existe uma só mulher que foi
significativo que foi representativo que
não passou por muita dor por muito
sofrimento por muito sacrifício
eu lembro da história de inácio de
loyola conhecido por muitos que nasceu
em 1491 aos 30 anos em pleno século 16
ele era um homem guerreiro em cavaleiro
na verdade foi ferido ferido de maneira
mortal até mas conseguiu tratamento
adequado teve a pena della sera da e por
conta de todas a dor e sofrimento
enquanto estava num processo de
tratamento
ele começou a refletir fazer leituras
enquanto refletia e fazia leitoras
ele começou a pensar uma espécie de
exército diferente não mais aquele tipo
de exército que ele tinha antes mas um
exército educativo
um exército que traria as pessoas para
aquilo que ele agora estava acreditando
foi aí que inácio de loyola criou a
companhia de jesus
a companhia de jesus que muitos de vocês
podem ouvir falar mas que são resto é
que é responsável por um reflexo aqui no
brasil é muito poderoso e são as pucs as
universidades católicas administradas
pelos jesuítas a companhia de jesus que
formou jesuítas que vieram catequizar os
índios aqui no brasil eu não estou
tentando evidência aqui os aspectos
negativos do processo eu acho que isso
pouco contribui
eu estou tentando evidenciar os aspectos
construtivos quando a gente pega a dor
ea partir da dor a gente consegue
construir algo diferente
é daí então com essa proposta o que eu
tenho dele para oferecer aos outros para
que a gente possa estabelecer o escambo
para que a gente possa fazer a troca eu
pensei eu posso convidar as pessoas para
viver as coisas que os índios vivem para
viver as coisas que nós temos desde
muito tempo eu peguei um ritual que é
muito antigo segundo as pinturas
rupestres e os arqueólogos existe há
mais de 20 mil anos ainda praticado nas
comunidades indígenas mas permitindo
apenas para indígenas ea partir de um
colega que era muito branco e dizia
assim
cara eu queria muito e não dei
participar dessas coisas lá não dá nem
pra dizer que é meu primo cara porque
não tem nada dele mas vamos pensar em
alguma coisa vamos pensar em algo que
vamos vamos fazer algo que eu já queria
fazer porque já estou inserido nessa
outra realidade
eu já estou na cidade e não quero que
meus filhos esqueçam que eles são e por
não queria que meus filhos esqueçam que
eles são
vamos criar então também aqui o ouricuri
aberto a todos porque a gente está
fazendo uma proposta que não é exclusiva
de um povo ela deve ser abraçada por
todos e como deve ser abraçada por todos
porque é uma forma de encarar a vida
cabe você também nessa e foi aí que a
gente começou fazendo longas caminhadas
eu não sei se posso falar longa que nem
é tão longa assim 150 quilômetros em
média nós andamos um pouco mais de 30
quilômetros por dia ea dificuldade
porque a gente carrega tudo que precisa
essa é uma das regras
tem gente que já morreu e diz que é um
sofrimento extremo se a gente tirar o
celular dela pois é nessa caminhada não
pode usar nada tecnológico não pode usar
celular
você tem que carregando tudo e as
pessoas quando começam a fazer a
caminhada num primeiro momento super
motivadas e empolgados
a gente sai daqui da capital maceió e
vai até a divisa com sergipe na foz do
rio são francisco
nos anos ímpares nós vamos até
pernambuco na divisa do estado saímos
sempre da capital
fazemos as rotas indígenas antigas
andando atravessando tudo a pé os rios a
nado e aí vamos carregando essas coisas
todas que quando as pessoas sentem o
peso da mochila elas percebem que
treinaram o tempo todo sem bolsa e
aquela bolsa representa o peso da vida
delas quanto mais conforto elas querem
mais peso elas precisam carregar e à
medida que elas andam é muito fácil se
perder na jornada porque é fácil se
perder na jornada porque se a gente não
estabelece bem onde a gente quer chegar
a gente nem começa a andar ou se começa
a andar dá voltas e não chega a lugar
nenhum e a proposta tanto noriko ir como
na vida de cada um de vocês aqui
primeiro estabeleçam muito bem onde
vocês precisam chegar mesmo que ao longo
do caminho vocês precisarem mudar a rota
mas é preciso caminhar com o objetivo as
pessoas quando começam a andar que
sentem o peso elas logo reclamam e dizem
eu não vou conseguir chegar é muito
longe sabe como a gente conforta a gente
chega para essas pessoas e colocar da
seguinte maneira
não pense lá no objetivo final apenas
não esqueça do objetivo final mas não
pense nele
pense somente na próxima parada que vai
ser daqui a três quilômetros
será que você consegue chegar até a
próxima parada daqui a três quilômetros
isso serve para a vida também
a gente traça objetivos grandes e fica
pensando neles mas a gente esquece que
para chegar neste objetivo maior é um
passo de cada vez
se a gente não distribuir esses passos
adequadamente se a gente não distribuiu
o ponto que a gente quer
pegar os pontos menores e se não
fizermos festas com essas pequenas
conquistas
a gente vai desmotivar ea gente não vai
chegar lá no ponto maior que a gente
espera então a pessoa anda e diz que
consegue chegar até o ponto de três
quilômetros quando chega lá eu pergunto
essa mesma pessoa
será que você consegue chegar no próximo
ponto de parada daqui é mais três
quilômetros
a pessoa disse sim no próximo encontro
consigo e assim ela vai de 3 em 3
quilômetros ela caminha
os mais de 30 quilômetros do dia e
quando terminar este lhe á no próximo
dia a jornada continua ea maior parte
das pessoas consegue e eu digo que é
quase totalidade na verdade consegue
porque a dinâmica do ouricuri não é você
chegar até o último ponto que foi
estabelecida mas é você dar o melhor de
si e só parar quando de fato não há mais
condições
quando você pára porque não há de fato
mais condições
a gente disse que você cumpre uma
jornada pelo menos você fez tudo que era
possível fazer com as condições que você
estava isso é fantástico isso é
transformador e cada dia a gente coloca
um tema específico a gente define sempre
algo para as pessoas pensarem ao longo
dessa jornada enquanto as pessoas
caminho elas vão refletindo e um dos
pontos que a gente coloca é o seguinte
ao longo do caminho nós passaremos por
dores ao longo do caminho
nós passaremos por desconforto ao longo
do caminho nós passaremos por
perseguições se não pararmos passamos
este é um ponto importante
não podemos parar precisamos continuar
independente das dores calos surgiram e
as escalas servirão também para
pensarmos a própria vida da gente no
nosso emprego aquele chefe chato aquele
colega que fala mal da gente
a inveja geralmente surge nessas
relações entre os iguais e as pessoas
que tentam nos atormentar
quem nunca fez uma longa caminhada e
precisou caminhar porque tem um objetivo
com um calo no pé
não pode entender muito bem com o outro
fala esta pessoa é um calo no meu pé e
veja
mesmo com um calo no pé a gente precisa
continuar a jornada este é um ótimo
educativo muito grande e aí eu volto
para o meu perfil do professor aquele
perfil que eu tenho falado lá
inicialmente eu explico sempre para os
alunos
a dor nos organismos mais avançados como
nós humanos
ela é processada no sistema nervoso
central e uma área que se chama giro do
cíngulo tanto dores físicas como dores
emocionais e é muito claro pra gente em
todos os experimentos que fazemos sempre
que conseguimos estabelecer metas
objetivos e educamos as pessoas para se
focar nessas metas e nesses objetivos
até a área do cérebro que é estimulada
ela diminui porque o foco se tornar algo
maior por isso que é importantíssimo não
nos desviamos dos nossos objetivos por
isso que é importantíssimo termos esses
objetivos quando temos objetivos que são
pessoais
olhamos - para a vida dos outros nos
importamos menos com que as pessoas
fazem porque ficamos focados na nossa
própria vida este é um ponto que não
devemos esquecer esse com tudo isso
vocês ainda acham muito difícil e muito
distante a aceitar a proposta o convite
para participar de um programa de índio
eu queria destacar algo muito importante
a vida vai passar pra mim e para vocês
vai passar para quem também está sentado
no sofá mas ela vai passar de um modo
completamente diferente para quem se
lança para que o tolerado dor
para quem entende que em todas as
jornadas que traçamos as dores vão fazer
parte
assim como vocês eu também passa por
aflições eu também passa por
perseguições sabe o que muda é que a
gente entende que isso tudo faz parte
eu tenho certeza e quero deixar essa
mensagem para os meus filhos os meus
oito filhos os quais três estão aqui
presentes que a vida da gente
ela pode ser um filme monótono
quer mudar de canal ou pode ser um filme
extremamente interessante e que a gente
olha e é cheio de aventuras e cheia de
paixões senão não teria tantos filhos
também
muito obrigado a todos vocês a votar
[Aplausos]